the opening scene features an elderly
man named kazutaka who is heading a
financial advisory firm known as Tai
Corporation in the midst of a stormy
night he gathers all of his staff and
asks a question about what gives a
person the ultimate power each employee
takes their turn to respond presenting
varied answers yet none satisfy kazutaka
one of the employees named Rinko Endo is
even scolded when she answers that money
makes a person powerful at that moment
another staff member named Yukio
tonigawa proposes that establishing
one's own realm holds the greatest power
and his answer earns him praise from his
boss in the next scene we are introduced
to the protagonist named kaiji itel who
is financially broke and has a
monotonous lifestyle he works in a
grocery store and is barely able to meet
his basic needs and rent in a hope to
change his fate he time and again
invests in scratch-off tickets but loses
all the time one day on his way back
home kaiiji shows his frustration by
kicking all the expensive cars in the
parking lot when he kicks a Mercedes a
group of security guards Sue and
apprehend him for punishment a short
while later harenko steps out from the
same Mercedes and takes kaiji to a
nearby restaurant for a brief
conversation she shows him a loan
agreement he had co-signed as a
guarantor for a friend a couple years
back since his friend is unreachable
kaiji is now liable to repay the loan
much to his astonishment the interest
has compounded significantly resulting
in a debt of 2 million yen kaiiji is
clearly unable to pay the debt knowing
this fact renko offers him a chance to
participate in a gambling cruise saying
that if he wins all of his debt will be
wiped clean kaiji is reluctant about the
whole idea but since he has no other
choice he agrees later that same evening
kaiji makes his way to the gambling
cruise where he finds numerous fellow
participants who are financially broke
like him shortly after Yukio addresses
the participants and outlines the rules
of the game they are about to play first
of all each player is provided with
three stars each valued at one million
has none of the participants possess
sufficient funds these stars are
provided as loans a crewing interest at
a rate of one percent per minute
following this the players received 12
rock paper scissors cards to use during
the game Victor in each round allows
them to claim a star from their opponent
in order to secure Victory one has to
retain a minimum of three stars provided
that they must use all 12 cards within a
30 minute time frame with the rules
cleared Yukio initiates the countdown
for the game and walks away soon after
the situation starts getting intense as
people Rush here and there to find an
opponent and play amidst this flurry one
of the participants named joji funai
approaches kaiji who proposes a deal
that if they play a draw in every round
they can retain their stars without
having to lose the game kaiji consents
to this plan and they begin wasting
their cards and playing draws however at
one point joji deceives kaiji and
captures two of the stars from him this
enrages kaiji resulting in a physical
altercation between the two in the
middle of the fight joji's blood soils
kaiji's last card while security
intervenes to separate them joji
discloses that kaiji's final card is
scissors prompting others to surround
him for an easy star however kaiiji
quickly asserts that joji's card is Rock
diverting the participant's attention
towards joji in the meantime the
security Personnel escort a participant
named Koji Ishida back to the central
Hall reprimanding him for attempting to
dispose of his cards in the toilet their
toilets are so futuristic that they told
on him as the time is running out joji
announces that since nobody believes in
each other he has an he proposes to
reshuffle the cards to play a fair game
to which everyone agrees after this joji
shuffles all the cards and gives them
back to the participants coincidentally
kaiji receives the same blood-stained
card he then teams up with Koji and
challenges joji to a one-card match
betting three stars joji promptly agrees
because he knows kaiji's last card but
to his surprise our protagonist defeats
him here it's revealed that kaiji
cleverly swapped his card with kojis
strategically adding blood in order to
deceive joji with the lost match joji
has taken away by security while kaiiji
and Koji retain Their Stars however
another twist unfolds when Koji suddenly
finds a card in his pocket upholding his
promise to teamwork kaiiji claims the
card is his own causing both of them to
lose in the aftermath of this event the
defeated participants are transported
deep below the Earth's surface and are
forced to serve as slaves in the
construction of kazitaka's Kingdom
despite the grueling Labor Works they
aren't provided with proper meals and
are forced to sleep on the bear floor in
addition microchips are fitted in their
bodies preventing them from escaping the
place in remuneration for their work
though they receive kazutaka's currency
called perika which is valued at a mere
one-tenth of the Japanese Yen regardless
of the minimal salary kaiji remains
Resolute in amassing enough money to
clear his debt one perika is worth less
than one tenth of a penny and pennies
don't even exist anymore good luck kaiji
however a day arrives when guards bring
in an array of beer and some delicious
foods luring the exhausted workers
although initially resistant kaiji
succumbs to Temptation prompting him to
spend all of his salary on delicious
food and chilled beer good good luck
kaiji the next day an earthquake rocks
the tunnel causing injuries among
several workers including Koji kaiji
rushes him to the infirmary only to find
that treatment requires perica payment
this disheartening reality shatters hope
until a doctor reveals a last chance for
Liberation the brave men Road emerging
victorious in this game promises Freedom
while losing it would claim their
later on names are gathered for the
brave men Road stage driven by his
determination to get out of this hell
kaiji decides to take the risk and
volunteers to participate in it this
inspires others including Koji so they
follow him as well after this they are
blindfolded and tied before taking them
to their destination once unblindfolded
they find themselves standing atop the
tallest building where Yukio is also
present to host the game of life and
death at first the participants are
handed a cash voucher worth 10 million
yen and in order to redeem it they must
go to another building via two narrow
beam paths at immense height to make the
game tougher they aren't allowed to
crawl or else they'll be electrocuted
these rules are formulated to make the
game interesting because a group of
wealthy folks are watching this as their
entertainment no doubt a crew of
Psychopathic obese American pervs
although scared at first the
participants gather their courage and
start walking on the beam trying to
maintain their balance over time they
managed to cover a distance of
approximately five meters but their
progress is interrupted by the sudden
onset of lightning intense defying Their
Fear one of the group members gets so
scared that he starts feeling the wind
pushing him and as a result he slips his
foot gets electrocuted and falls to his
death the tragic sight makes the other
players Panic as well and they start
falling over one after another on the
other hand the wealthy folks enjoy the
fall much tarinka is disgust now only
kaiji Koji and another player named
Makoto remain on the beam to add to
their problems it starts raining making
the beams slippery kaiiji and Makoto are
still determined to complete the task
but in contrast Koji claims that he is
not able to continue he gives his
voucher to kaiiji asking him to redeem
it and hand it over to his debt-ridden
daughter after this Koji commits The
Unthinkable by falling from there ending
his misery once and for all despite the
tragedy both the other participants
remain undeterred and they successfully
reach the other side however their
Triumph is short-lived as kaiji senses
something amiss when he observes
kazutaka looking at them from a window
in a sudden gust the window slams open
throwing Makoto off the bill building to
his death kaiji narrowly avoids a
similar fate as he somehow manages to
hold on to the ledge and climb back once
he gets inside the building kazitaka and
his associates applaud kaiji's Victory
and extend their congratulations kaiji
is then presented with 7 million yen the
remainder after his deaths are settled
he also seeks to claim koji's fonts but
Yukio says that a deceased person's
vouchers of no use enraged kaiji lunges
at Yukio but the guards swiftly
intervene impressed by kaiji's fiery
determination kazitaka offers him one
more chance to engage in another game
called e-card with Yukio as his opponent
in this game each player is given five
cards featuring four citizens and either
an emperor or a slave according to the
game rules the participants choosing the
slave card can make the first move
furthermore citizen vs citizen is a draw
and a citizen card beats the slave while
the emperor beats the citizen and the
slave beats the emperor that chance the
outcome of three rounds determines the
ultimate Victor following this kaiji
chooses the card representing the slave
side and initiates the game with it yeah
you you got this bro in the first round
the duo plays two citizen cards
resulting in a draw however when he
proceeds with the slave card a third
time Yukio is able to anticipate it and
secures victory in the subsequent round
kaiji closely observes Yukio and notices
an odd behavior he keeps on looking at
the bottom kaiiji then decides to
forward the slave card but Yukio once
again predicts his move and defeats him
having lost two out of the three rounds
kaiji is captured by the guards who are
about to lead him back to the
underground tunnel for labor works
during this he notices a different watch
on Yu-Gi-Oh's wrist while he's being
taken away kaiji tries to figure out how
he lost and comes to a realization the
microchip implanted in his body serves
as the key to all of this and yukio's
watch allows him to monitor kaiji's
physiological indicators after realizing
all of the tricks kaiji devises a plan
to deal with the situation he requests
for a bathroom break once inside he
calls Rinko who is standing at the door
he then unveils his scheme to her asking
her for a loan of 50 million yen backed
by his conviction that he can win in the
last round after a bit of deliberation
Rinko agrees and the two return back to
the gaming Hall kazitaka is happy to
watch more games so he permits one more
match just before the game begins kaiji
strikes his head against a mirror
shattering it in order to disrupt the
functionality of yukio's watch signal he
then gets on his table where he grabs
three cards hiding them in his lap
secretly he exchanges one of the cards
on the table with the one concealed on
his lap as kaiji shakes his head the two
remaining cards on the table acquire
bloodstains soon the game begins and
this time Yukio appears to be nervous
because he can't rely on his watch any
longer they both start with citizen
cards resulting in a draw in the next
round kaiji forwards a card with a blood
stain seeing this yukio's memory
triggers reminding him that the
blood-stained cards on the table were a
citizen and a slave as a result he picks
his citizen card for this round
coincidentally kaiji's card turns out to
be a citizen once again leading to
another draw at this point Yukio grows
confident that kaiji's remaining blood
stint card must be a slave following one
more draw kaiji forwards another
blood-stained card thinking that it's a
slave Yukio is about to play a citizen
but at the same time he realizes that he
swapped the blood-stained card before
starting the game remembering a similar
trick used by kaiiji earlier in the
cruise Yukio deduces that the card on
the table is in fact a citizen with this
confidence Yukio plays the Emperor card
only to be jolted by shock as kaiji's
card is revealed yeah akunai with chain
just kidding to be a slave in the
ultimate turn of events kaiji gains a
victory over Yukio kaiji unveils his
trick admitting that he never actually
swapped the card it was merely a
pretense following the loss Kazi talk
events his anger on Yukio and punishes
him by sending him underground to work
as a slave in the next scene we see
kaiiji and Rinko at a restaurant where
they enjoy their lunch shortly after
kaiiji passes out as Reiko seems to have
drugged his drink when he regains his
Consciousness he discovers that rinco is
gone with all of the money leaving
behind a letter that states she has
taken the money because of the interest
per minute on the loan in the end kaiiji
is left with only 450 000 Yen regardless
he goes to koji's daughter's workplace
and delivers all of the remaining money
fulfilling his promise a kunai with
chain a kunai with chain yeah a kunai
with chain subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching